the now is pointed to this now now it
has already ceased to be in the act of
pointing to it the now that is is
another now than the one pointed to and
we see that the now is just this to be
no more just when it is the narrow as it
is pointed out to us is now that has
been and this is its truth it is not the
truth of being yeah this much is true
that it has been but what essentially
has been is in fact not an essence that
is it is not and it was with being that
we were concerned
so in section 106 which is pretty short
we're going to be talking a lot about
now but it's not really now is it
because at every moment when I say now
you could actually look at what time
stamp there is on the video and you can
say well that was that now and now he's
doing something else that that now is
way back there we have this sort of
depiction of a continuum of time we
usually draw out as kind of an arrow
going from from past to future or going
from future to past depending on the way
we're thinking about it and this is
precisely Hegel's point if we're going
to try to get back to this now we're
going to be unsuccessful Wow
well since the now is pointed to this
now so the subject the eye is pointing
to the now in which they're currently
living experiencing you could say they
inhabit that now it is there now but he
says now it has already ceased to be in
the act of pointing to it why me because
pointing to it took a little bit of time
and so now is really that
or in the past now it's no longer than
now it's no longer the present so we
could put it like that so we've got past
a headline we've got this little slice
of time that happens to be the present
well maybe we just need to like you know
sort of like when you're shooting a
shotgun you ain't him a little bit ahead
of you know the bird or the the target
the clay pigeon that you're going to
shoot at maybe we just didn't need to
track a little bit ahead so could we
maybe telescope and hug to hear well you
have no idea what the hell's out there
so that's not actually being the work
we're stuck with this process where
we're moving forward from now - now -
now so he says it's already ceased to be
in the act of pointing to it that now
that is this now is another now than the
one pointed to and we see that the now
is just this this is what the essence of
the now or you know broader terms
temporality that we human beings live in
that's what the essence of it actually
yes - not - no more to be no more just
when it is so this is actually not yet
or it's not this is what it is so you
know maybe the eye says great I'll point
out that now well nope oh here over here
and we can keep doing this process as
long as we want
we're never actually going to be able to
get to the now at least in
sense-perception
the way that we want to now we can say
when we're editing videos or when we're
monkeying around with soundtracks can't
we but they are what are we doing we've
recorded something it's no longer the
actual now it's just a copy of it and
we're monkeying around with the
temporality you know the structure of
time for that you know we can actually
cut out a piece of the video and stick
it in over here great example when I
record these videos you're watching me
reading something and then commenting on
it but usually I've gotten to the point
where all read the text and I do all of
that reading in one place so that
there's continuity before I actually
start recording anything any of these
things so in the case of this particular
video the the recording of my reading
the text occurred about a month before
my standing in front of the chalkboard
so we're able to do all this kind of
configuration but it's not real time
that we're working with it's not the
time of cents certainty or sense
perception it's something that we've
manipulated so Hegel says that now that
that is as it is now that it's been and
this is its truth yeah it's not the
truth of being but this much is true
that it has been this is an on being but
it's also a kind of being because it's
not totally lacking and being takes a
little bit of thinking for this says
this much is true that it has been but
what is essentially has been is in fact
not an essence that yes there is
constantly a decision between what has
been and what is the trouble is this
dividing line is not something that
stays constant it keeps on moving
forward we don't have control over it so
he says it is not and it was with being
that we were concerned so have we
obtained what we wanted do we possess
sense certainty or not it starts to look
like we don't actually have it because
the immediacy that we were trying to
recapture in all of this turns out to be
rather illusory
in this pointing out then we see merely
a movement which takes the following
course first I point out the now and it
is asserted to be the truth I pointed
out however is something that has been
or something that has been superseded I
set aside that first truth
I now assert as the second truth that it
has been that it is superseded but what
has been is not I set aside the second
truth its having been at its Super
Session and thereby negate the negation
of the now and thus return to the first
assertion that that now is the now and
pointing out them now are the so
constituted that neither the one nor the
other is immediate and simple but a
movement which contains various moments
in this is positive but it is rather and
other that is positive or the this is
superseded and this other Nisour the
setting aside of the first is itself in
turn set aside and so has returned into
the first however this first thus
reflected into itself is not exactly the
same as it was to begin with then it is
something immediate on the contrary it
is something that is reflected into
itself or a simple entity which it as
other nanine's what it is and now which
it is an absolute plurality of nails and
this is the true the genuine now the now
is a simple day which contains in itself
many nouns hours and now of this sort an
hour similarly it is many minutes and
this now is likewise many doubts and so
on the pointing out of the now is thus
itself the movement which expresses what
that now is in truth that is a result or
a plurality of now knows all taken
together and the pointing out is the
experience of learning that now is a
reversal
so in the first part of section 107
Hegel is actually explaining to us what
just happened we thought that we had
sent certainty finally you know we had a
complete grip on it we grasped it we
restored the immediacy that we lost and
suddenly everything started slipping
away as happens with the dialectic
things don't turn out to be what we
thought originally and as soon as we try
to hold them fast just like that now
point we find out no it's not just here
it's also over here and what we're
holding on to turns out to be less
essential and that's more essential
that's what drives our process of
thinking so in this act of pointing
that's involved with with sense
certainty as we've just gone through in
the last couple of passages there is
this succession of truths succession of
realizations that are happening first I
point out now as being truth and I
realized that now is what has been that
it's not what is in the pure now and the
present but by the very act of like
getting ready to point it out I'm
already a little bit beyond my self into
a time where I'm reflecting back and
saying this now here that no longer is
that has been is what I was talking
about so this this first truth is going
to be as we say superseded or overcome
of coholan and this isn't a key term in
the Galleon dialectic it shows us
there's some sort of advance going on
here
and so like he says I set aside the the
first truth and now I have a second
truth and setting aside the first truth
in saying no look this it really isn't
what I was after this this can't be the
case this isn't what is essential that
itself is a truth and so the second
truth is that the first truth is
superseded so that it's been overcome or
sublated however you want to translate
it is that where we're gonna stop if we
were skeptics that's where we'd stop and
say yeah I can't do anything but
Hegel says that the second truth itself
can be located in this kind of sequence
as well and so the second truth is also
something that has been and just like a
celebrity that points out that another
celebrity is no longer a real celebrity
anymore
but has been a past one and then that
celebrity gets that pointed out by some
other younger fresher face that's what
happens with this this third truth it
points out to the second truth well you
know you also have been so you're no
longer what you really need to be and
you are also superseded this is what
Hegel calls negating the negation of the
now so does that mean that just like
with you know two minus signs sequel to
a positive sign or rather we've linked
to it equal right we have numbers in
there could be equal to it no because
this is this is a pelham logic this
isn't just the kind of logic that we use
in mathematics or formal logic the
negation of the negation is something
yet else new
so the now is but it's no longer and now
a pure immediate see right he's gonna
tell us this he says here we go the now
and pointing out them now are the so
constituted that neither the one nor the
other is something immediate and simple
but a movement which contains various
moments so this pointing which I do
because I am the subject the sense
certainty that contained the object that
revealed itself to have a universal in
it all of this is still bound up you
remember just a few passages passages
ago when Hegel was saying well we get to
restore immediacy we do so by
encompassing everything in it and so
having them now that is in this
dialectical advance is actually a better
more systematic grasp of what we mean
so he says this is positive but it is
rather and other than is positive or
that this is superseded and this other
ness of the setting aside of the first
isn't it strands set aside and so is
return to the first however this first
thus reflected into itself is not
exactly the same as it was to begin with
see now that is is not exactly the same
as the now that we we started right here
how is it different
well Hegel has just told us it is a
movement which contains various moments
it contains
if you want to call them parts you can
components or elements or constituents
would probably be better than parts
because parts gives us the idea that
what we're talking about is something
that we could take apart into its parts
like like a mechanism and that's not
exactly what he has in mind so he says
here we go it's it's it's now which is
an absolute plurality of Mouse so what
does it mean for it to be a plurality of
now it means that there is a whole bunch
of thousand this is what it means to say
now it means to gesture not just at this
present moment that we're calling now
but also to include the now of you
watching this video I mean think about
that for a second right now right now I
am actually here in front of this video
that's why it's able to record you know
the video cameras doing something and
then I'm gonna put it on my computer and
I'm gonna watch myself and I'm gonna you
know edit a little bit change the
lighting to make it a little bit
brighter boost the sound a bit and
that's still the same now except now
it's at a different time isn't it and
then you might be watching this ten
years from now
you might watch these things totally on
a sequence the now is a for reality of
knows it can't be confined
to any single one of those instances the
now is a universal so like he says you
know here's an example of this and now
of this sort and our you know a day
contains with it many and now is ours
and now this sort is many minutes that
this now is likewise many nouns so it's
not just a plurality in the sense of
being a whole bunch of individual units
each of these units is also a plurality
it can be broken down further we can say
the same thing for space by the way to
with the here though this works that way
so he says the pointing out of the now
is thus itself the movement which
expresses what the now is in truth that
is a result or a plurality of nails all
taken together and the pointing out is
the experience of learning at the now is
a plurality or a we have universal
the here pointed out to which I hold
fast is similarly a this here which in
fact is not this year but a before and a
behind and above and below a right and
left the obamas similarly this manifold
other nacelles cetera the here which was
supposed to have been pointed out
vanishes in other years but these
likewise vanish
what has pointed out held fast and
abides is a negative this which is
negative only when the hearers are taken
as they should be but it being so taken
they supersede themselves what abides is
a simple complex of many here's the here
that is meant would be the point but it
is not on the contrary when it is
pointed out it is something that is the
pointing out shows itself to be not an
immediate knowing of the point but a
movement from the here that is met
through many years into the universal
here which is a simple plurality of
years just as the date as a simple
plurality of NAS
the entire dialectical process that we
just engaged in in the last several
paragraphs with respect to them now that
is with respect to temporarily can be
done in relation to spaciality and so
Hegel's going to you know for good
reason follow this out all the way
spaciality doesn't work exactly the same
way as temporality does so we do want to
be a bit cognizant about some of those
differences and we'll talk about that in
a little bit but let's see where these
actually saying first so he says the
here pointed out to which I hold fast is
similarly a this here and I think any
particular thing so I pick here this
particular spot in space that's not the
entirety of space isn't it's not even
the entirety of space when I'm just
looking at or let's say we take the
chalkboard right and both of us look at
the same thing I'm looking at this
little dot right here and you look at
that little dot right there don't look
at me over here only look at that little
dot don't pay attention those are the
man behind the curtain or the man in
front of the curtain you can't do it can
you what we take in through sense
perception is actually a manifold now
you might say with some senses it is
possible for us to do this sort of thing
for example when we hear a sound that is
so powerful perhaps because of its it's
a loudness or some other quality that it
drowns out all other sounds but does
that work for spaciality in general not
really not so long as we had a sight
that so long as we have touch I mean I'm
not even sure that you can say that this
would work for taste or for for odor
Hegel's not worrying about anything like
that at this point but if but it's an
interesting speculation in any case you
can't concentrate on just the here
because when you look at it the here
breaks down into a whole bunch of
moments so he says this here
the one that we're pointing at right
there is not this here but also they
before or in front right and behind
we're adding one dimension of death I'm
closer to you I'm further away from you
the eraser is in front of me now it's
behind me you get the idea right yeah
I'm not gonna have to go through that
with all these dimensions I look for you
two ready to get a good sense of it so
we've gotten you know one dimension
they're already depth and then we can
talk about above and below so we have
height as well and then we have left and
right we have all three dimensions of
space and with any single one of these
or any combination of them we can talk
about the here no longer being the here
in relation to another here here is
actually whatever here we pick it's
always located in relation to a whole
multiplicity of other tiers so what is
it that's going on when we say here well
let's look here and see what he has to
say here and now they allow for a lot of
puns don't they so he says the here is
not this here but all these dimensions
the above itself is similarly this
manifold other nosov and below so
whatever thing we're going to decompose
this into let's not just take a bob
let's take the left right the left
becomes of you here whatever it is
that's to the left my case this trough
work well that also has all of these all
these different spatial dimensions as
well so you know now I'm actually to the
left of the chalkboard and you can't see
me because I've gone off the camera
where I think at least I think you can't
see me we can do this for any one of
these and we use keep keep on going and
going and going that's what it means for
space to actually be a continuum we can
decompose it further and say halfway
not quite you know all the way behind
but just partly behind we can we can
make this as complicated as we want to
so he says any one of these is a
manifold other nests the same sort of
thing to here which was supposed to been
pointed out vanishes in other years
that's where it gets really interesting
again when it comes to our senses and
sense certainty and the immediacy that
that was supposed to bring and the very
certainty and truth the richness of it
the concrete reality that we're being
confronted with it always turns out to
decompose into something less than what
we had originally wanted and expected
and it only stays what it is so long as
we insist that it's staying that way so
the here becomes something negative and
notice that unlike with temporality
where you just have you know a
succession of Mouse you can go in
whatever direction you want if we had
more dimensions I suppose it could get
really really complicated you know who
would notice how many dimensions there
really are the space
Hegel's not not so concerned about that
but I suppose if he was here in the
present he might be trying to you know
understand some of the physical theories
so he says the here you know what what
is pointed out and held fast and abides
as a negative this which is negative
only when the hears are taken away as
there should be but in being so taken
they supersede themselves what it binds
is a simple complex of many hears or a
universal so whenever we're using this
term here and we're engaging in this
practice of pointing out a here or there
or this or that whether we're doing so
with our finger or whether we're doing
so with our eyeballs or whether we're
doing so in language we are using this
universal that in relation to any of the
particular instances is negative and
negative this is kind of empty it's like
a schema that we can fit things into but
that's the exact function of the here
that
what it does it allows for all of these
possibilities and all of them to go off
into their own you know folder
possibilities and these possibilities to
hook up with each other and to connect
into one big manifold of spaciality so
he says the here that is meant would be
the point whatever we're picking out
this here so just decide up behind here
what's behind this chalkboard well it's
a bunch of books you know a bunch of
shelves so you pick that and you say hey
dr. Sadler I want to see what's back
there
show me that the chalkboard you know
flip it over you can't do it actually
because the way things are designed but
you have something particular in mind
something that's meant but when I when I
gesture out to here in general in
relation to that all I've got is a
negative schema what allows you to take
that schema and apply it not just to
this here but also to this here the fact
that it is negative the fact that it's
not tied down to one single instance the
fact that it can signify the fact that
it can go over this entire range that's
an achievement so he says on the
contrary when it's pointed out as
something that is pointing to this the
pointing out shows itself to not be in
an immediate knowing of that point but a
movement from the here that is meant
through many years into the universal
here which is a simple plurality of
years just as the day is a simple
plurality of nouns so any here just like
with the the now that I you know I say
now but I'm actually over here and this
now any here that I want to pick out I'm
not actually signifying what it is that
I intend because it drags along with it
all these connections to all these other
here's you can't isolate a point in
space or a object in space as totally
separate
from everything else because that's the
way here works because here is a
universal because here not here like
where I am but here over there on the
board because here is something that we
need in order to be able to make sense
of our understanding and our engagement
with spatial spatial objects with
spaciality with even our own bodies as
where they are so if we put these two
together we see that not only can we not
pick out any one single moment or any
one single spatial point as being purely
what it is and having a totally
immediate relation to that we can't do
that even with the grand schemas that
we're trying to cram them into they all
end up requiring each other in order to
be made sense of so the truth of set
certainty is we're moving ahead turns
out to be this comprehensive whole that
we are articulating